hey it's evan and for the past few days
i've been getting into a fight with this
spammer
and i wanted to get your feedback on it
to let me know if i'm on the right path
if i'm in the right here or if you
disagree with me okay i'm gonna go
through the the history of the emails
and i want your feedback let me know
what you think leave a comment tell me
your thoughts okay so this guy dinsdale
writes to me on linkedin so i don't know
who he is
and he wrote in and he said evan have
you thought about making an extra income
from professional blogging so obviously
he doesn't know that i actually make a
great income from blogging already the
technology has certainly come of age
blogbeast.com with his i'm assuming id
here so let's click on this you load
this up and it's some huge spam thing
right your typical sales letter
so dude is spamming me right he's put no
effort into it he doesn't know anything
about me obviously he's just trying to
get me to sign up
usually i ignore these things right
usually i've been ignoring spammers i'm
sure all you guys do too but this time i
decided you know what i'm going to write
back to him i'm going to see if i can
help change this guy's business so
here's my response to him come on dens
the spamming people on linkedin really
working for you i know it's hard getting
people to sign up for something new and
you really want this thing to work for
you but you're focused on the wrong
marketing if you want to have success
you want people talking about you right
now all they'll say is din is a spammer
the key is to stand for something what
do you believe in that will move people
what is your strong opinion that you
need to share with the world believe in
it passionately share expertise create
content that people actually want to
share and they'll do it
and you'll get people coming to your
website and signing up you'll feel
better about yourself and get way better
results wishing you the best of luck ins
i hate seeing entrepreneurs struggle
especially when they have noble goals
and want to make a difference believe
evan this is my response so i don't know
how much time you guys spend with
spammers but i felt like you know what
i'm going to try to make a difference
with this guy
so then we got into an email battle i'm
going to share with you and again i want
your feedback this is what he writes
back
evan i've only just realized what a
condescending oik you are whatever oik
is better late than never i've got
access to 25 million dollars and more
fool
so let's scroll down see what i wrote
back to him here dinsdale our friend
dinsdale so i just wrote back best of
luck d i figured you know what
this guy's not getting it i'm not going
to waste my time best of luck do your
thing whatever he decides right back to
me again why do some people who think
they have position and money think they
have the right to insult others they
assume are not up to their social
standing rhetorical
it is pompous eventually they'll be torn
down a stripper too
my response
dee you're totally missing a point i
want you to be successful i responded to
you challenging you to be better not to
spam people to stand for something to
make your business important and mean
something
all i called you was a spammer which you
are at least for now and i hope that'll
change
while you decided to call me
condescending of fulham pompous i came
from making 300 bucks a month and not
surviving and i made it through success
is entirely possible for you but you
have to warn it and it's not going to
come by spamming people and if you're
going to keep spamming people then i
have no interest in helping you
response evan there
that that is where you are missing the
point you don't you don't see see you
don't see c just how assumptive you're
being asked of your being which
consequently means you don't see how
condescending you sound quite insulting
many people have sent me emails about
various subjects
some i have absolutely no interest in
whatsoever but because i respect the
contact i try to help not write back
accusing him of spamming i don't know
why he's defending that he's not
spamming but anyway especially when we
have had prior conversations maybe you
could do some coaching on how to deal
with people effectively but with respect
my response all right dee i tried wish
you the best of luck in all the
adventures cheers evan believe no
response back let me know what you think
i'm curious to get your feedback how
would you handle it am i the fool is
dinsdale the fool i want to hear your
thoughts leave it below let's see what
happens thank you guys i'll see you soon
you